Now let's discuss how both
the initiator and responder
can compute shared keys based on the
information that they just exchanged.
In our example, the initiator and
responder have a pre-shared secret key,
and based on the information exchanged
between the initiator and responder,
they can both compute the following
keys using a pseudo-random function.
The pseudo-random function
can be built using HMAC and
SHA-1 to generate
a pseudo-random bitstream.
Recall that HMAC's SHA-1 takes
a message, say a block of data, and
a key of length at least 160 bits,
and produces a 160 bit hash value.
SHA-1 has the property that the change
of a single bit of the input produces
a new hash value with no apparent
connection to the preceeding hash value.
This property is the basis for
pseudo-random number generation.
Both the initiator and
responder computer root share secret.
This is computed using
the pre-shared key and
the nonce values that
they have exchanged.
Next, they compute a key for IPSec SA,
this key is computed as follows.
They use the root secret as the key for
the pseudo-random function and the info
data block contains four values.
The first one is K,
which is a shared secret key computed
using the Diffie-Hellman
case change protocol.
Second, the computer shared key
used to derive keys for IPSec SAs.
This key is computed using
the pseudo-random function
on the root secret and
the input blog contains four values.
The first one, K,
is the shared secret key computed using
the Diffie-Hellman key
exchange protocol.
The second and
third values are the cookies exchanged
between the initiator and the responder,
and the fourth value is the number zero.
Then in a similar fashion,
both the initiator and
responder compute the keys for IKE
message authentication and encryption.